welcome to another famous friday i
believe that whatever goal you have with
your business
somebody has already gone out and
accomplished it and the fastest way
to accomplish your goal is to model what
worked for other people and apply it to
your business
today's lessons from howard hughes the
legendary entrepreneur
and his messages think big howard hughes
loved to think big one of his famous
quotes was i intend to be the greatest
golfer in the world the finest film
producer in hollywood
the greatest pilot in the world and the
richest man in the world
now talk about thinking big the golf
career didn't really work out for him
but for hollywood
he created a film studio and he won
academy awards
for the airplanes for the pilots he
created an airline company created
custom airplanes
and set world records for speed of how
fast an airplane can go
and he drove them he flew them himself
and for the richest man in the world
he became a billionaire who became one
of the first billionaires
and was one of the wealthiest people in
the world and this is because he set big
goals for himself
and he believed in himself and every day
he took a step forward
to getting closer to that goal you need
to set big goals for yourself and this
is the problem that a lot of
entrepreneurs face where
one day you may wake up you're full of
energy something happened to you yeah
wow i'm i don't know where those energy
came from i'm gonna change the world i
have this big goal this is what i'm
gonna accomplish
and then you're going you're working
hard and the next day you wake up
and the energy is gone it's because the
environment that you've created for
yourself
holds you where you are right the media
you consume the people you hang around
with
your daily routine holds you where you
are
if you want to go out and accomplish
your big goal if you want to go out
and change the world you need to design
an environment that supports you better
and part of that should be surrounding
yourself with people like howard hughes
now howard hughes has long passed away
but you could still be surrounded by him
read his books see see his interviews
learn from his stories
that can motivate you to keep going to
keep thinking big even if that's the
only person telling you think big
when you're surrounded by people who
think small that one shining little
beacon of light
can be all that you need to keep going
every day
continue to think big and start to
achieve your goals there's a great quote
that i love
that talks about shooting for the moon
and even if you miss
you fall amongst the stars i want you to
think big
design an environment that supports you
and belief
for those of you watching you liked the
video subscribe to the channel
thank you so much and i'll see you soon
if you want the real goods i share my
best advice for entrepreneurs every week
in my newsletter
click the link below to check it out
it's free